Pokemon Sun and Moon is now out and has
a lot of new features in it so many in
fact that it can be a little hard to
keep track of so here are some tips and
tricks for you to get the most out of
your Pokemon experience the QR scanner
is a feature that lets you well scan QR
codes each scan gives you information
about Pokemon which is cool for those of
you with fondness for scanners but it
also serves a larger purpose every skin
gets through ten points and once you
reach 100 points you unlock island scan
which lets you search an island for a
rare Pokemon any QR code will work but
if you need one your pokedex has codes
for Pokemon you have caught so invite
your friends over and have a scanning
party once you activate island scan you
are given a location and a limited time
to catch it make sure to activate island
scan on an island you have fully
explored otherwise you might not be able
to make it in time to the Pokemon trials
are the replacements for gyms in Sun and
Moon and I got to post trial tips for
you while a trial is happening you can't
catch any Pokemon in that area so it's
always a good idea to revisit these
areas after the trial is over so you
don't miss any Pokemon to catch the
second tip after beating a trial head to
the PokeMart as you unlock new items to
purchase
Pokemon refresh is the Sun and moons
version of pokémon-amie
from X&Y where you can pet and feed your
Pokemon to raise their affection which
gives wonderful benefits such as XP
boosts higher accuracy and dodge and
even higher crit rates you can also
enter refresh rate after a battle where
you must clean and care for your Pokemon
and can help remove status ailments like
poison you probably don't want to use
Pokemon refresh after every battle as
that would get a little tedious but it
is worth hopping in there every once in
a while to keep your Pokemon healthy and
happy
the HMS from previous Pokemon games have
been completely removed and replaced
with writable pokemon that served the
same functions like Toros for rock smash
and Lapras for swim but the one you want
to keep bringing up whenever you can is
stout land a massive dog like Pokemon
who will sniff out items for you
stat 'land is also a much faster means
of travel basically replacing the roller
blades from X&Y
a fantastic upgrade if you ask me the
Pokemon daycare has also been replaced
with a new building the nursery it's
pretty much the same thing with one key
difference your Pokemon no longer level
up making the nursery purely for making
eggs which also makes it a lot cheaper
and honestly I'm okay with this leveling
up in the daycare was always an
expensive slow process and if your
Pokemon learn to move while in the
daycare it would automatically override
another move which was just a huge pain
so you never really wanted to level up
while in the daycare anyway and it
really just got in the way of our real
goal making babies the Z moves is one of
Sun and moons big new features powerful
beefed up attacks that deal massive
damage and play out like a Final Fantasy
summon
in order for your Pokemon to do easy
move you have to equip them with Z
crystals there's a crystal for each type
of move don't forget to actually equip
your Z crystals on your pokemons
otherwise they can't do the move and
also don't be afraid to try out
different Z crystal types on Pokemon as
long as your Pokemon has a move of that
type they can use that crystal this is a
staple of Pokemon games but it's worth
reminding you to take the time to talk
with every NPC you encounter apart from
getting some pretty funny dialogue you
can also get free items and characters
who will tell you important information
like a pokemons friendship level there's
also NPCs who will want to trade with
you and others who will simply want to
see a pokemons information on a pokedex
meaning you have to catch it and then
when you bring it back to them you get a
nice cash reward the Pokemon peligro is
a collection of small islands you can
visit after getting the ability to fly
here all your PC box Pokemon will hang
out and you can see how they're doing
the starting island has a beanstalk that
will grow beans for you daily in
addition to using these beans to feed
your Pokemon and Pokemon refresh you can
also use these beans to invest in the
creation of other islands that will do
things like grow berries for you or have
your Pokemon explore caves for items
it's worth taking the time each day to
collect all your goodies from the telugu
pokemon festival is the new hub location
for battles and trades with other real
players an avatar of a player can visit
your plaza through the use of the 3ds
local wireless communication or the good
old fashioned internet and you can view
their stats and recent events in the
game you can also send them to try out
one of your festivals games and stalls
which you can swap out over time you can
also play and buy from these stalls
yourselves which get you things like
items and stat boosts for your Pokemon
make sure you hop into the festival
Plaza to interact with people and get
some goodies and there are some good
beginner tips you should remember when
exploring the region of Aloha
for those of you who have just picked up
the game and are playing let me know in
the comments which started Pokemon you
picked and what your favorite part of
the game is so far
I picked RAL it just look at that guy
what a cutie for more coverage of
Pokemon Sun and Moon stay tuned to game
spot